des dizaines de milliers de drapeaux aux
couleurs de l'ukraine un peu partout sur
la planète ce samedi
comme cette marée humaine à times square
à new york
adultes et enfants ont investi la rue en
solidarité avec le peuple ukrainien pour
adresser un message aux dirigeants
internationaux
je crois que si les etats-unis l'otan et
l'union européenne décide d'une zone
d'exclusion aérienne
ils vont éviter que des gens ordinaires
moeurs des gens ordinaires pas l'armée
parce que les russes bombardent tout le
monde il s'en fiche
sur le vieux continent le même élan de
solidarité
ils sont des milliers dans les rues de
là et lisbonne zagreb paris et londres
beaucoup s'inquiètent du sort réservé
aux réfugiés
je pense qu'on doit accueillir plus se
réfugier ici dans ce pays
davantage à munich en allemagne les
manifestants ont formé une chaîne
humaine de 4 km entre les consulats
ukrainiens et russes certains d'entre
eux espèrent que vladimir poutine sera
un jour jugés devant la cour pénale
internationale
pendant des décennies nous avons soutenu
le comportement d'un despote nous en
occident on est tellement dépendants
économie ou pas le prix était
définitivement trop élevé et on s'en est
rendu compte trop tard cela ne peut pas
fonctionner comme ça c'est un fait rage
dans cette marée de bleu et de jaune un
autre message à émerger ces
manifestations sont dirigées contre un
seul homme le maître du kremlin et non
contre le peuple russe